i
am obsessed with flash gordon and i i
think you guys might be involved in this
and so
are you oh yes we are i can tell you all
about it if you want to hear
oh i very much but not too much but not
all right i'm only gonna i'm only going
to tell you
a little bit that's a lot so taika is
writing it
it was a movie that was a huge influence
on him
growing up it is one of his favorite
movies
he initially said to me let's do it
animated
i said okay then we got into it and
started developing it and he said no
let's do it live action
i said even better he
has the most fantastically
interesting vision for this movie
and and you can only know it is taika
it is what he does it is the way he
looks at the world
he is the greatest guy in the world he
is the funniest guy in the world
and he thinks on a different plane and
this movie embraces everything that's
special about taika
and his vision and how do you surprise
an audience
here's my follow-up to that taika is
like one
is probably one of the most in demand
people in hollywood right now
how do you do you envision this as
where can it fall on his schedule how
close are you with the script
that everyone's happy with well he's
writing it so
when somebody writes this script that
they're going to direct they're
obviously going to really like the
script
right so you get a big leg up right a
lot of times you know you go to a huge
director with somebody else's script and
it's he's got to reinvent it they got to
make it their own they got it whatever
this is going to be taika ready i've
been talking to taika
about this movie since i first saw his
thor
right and that's what made me huge well
in fact i saw the movie before that
right and he did this little movie in
new zealand that was just
insane that i loved it yeah fun for the
world
hunt for wilder people and that's the
first and that's what got me interested
in him and this and we sat down just to
talk in general we went to a bar
together
you know with this guy matt riley who
was an executive at fox
we started kicking around ideas and
and and so this is six years in the
making also right
so i've waited for him a lot a lot a lot
of time
but um his enthusiasm has remained
steadfast
and only he's going to be able to direct
this movie because only he should direct
this movie
it is special we've been through this
we've been through the development
process not the writing process but he's
laid out in great detail
the characters the movie the way in what
it's about the tone
all of that stuff right and you know
i i can't wait and we'll wait for him
and and hopefully we'll get
look he does a lot of movies right
believe it or not he can do a couple of
movies a year
no totally my my last question on flash
gordon even though
i have a million things from the music
to you name it
um is it connected at all to the
original film
with the queen music or is it a complete
redo
just with it has the same title it
hearkens
in a very interesting way it's the
original conception from the comic books
from the comics